[Music]
anytime I'm inside the cave I feel I'm
in a different time scale above the
ground is much faster the tree grows and
dies in like hundred years but inside
the caves it's millions of years and
it's timeless
[Music]
eleven miles north of Beirut hidden
inside a mountain lies the jato grotto
the pride of Lebanon and one of the most
majestic caves in the world when we say
it the cave everybody knows yet I gave
it's a very important cave because it's
the main water source of of Beirut and
area near Beirut a small portion of the
Jada grotto is open to the public
the rest is accessible only to a select
few
including this billiard club founded in
1951 it's the oldest most respected
caving Club in the Middle East the
spherically bomb was founded during the
explorations of Jada grotto the same
history of our club is the history of
Jada grotto every week this billiard
club gets together and girls caving in
The Grocer
when they explored they travel by birch
down a subterranean Black Lake
their mission is to discover new caves
map them photograph them and ultimately
protect them there's no doubt that she
that good is really a work of art simply
because of its huge scale and it's huge
formations and those formations aren't
set in stone the cave is very much alive
all of this is still under growing it's
not a fossil gave yet still living this
cave in the last 65 years the Spiller
Club has discovered over 600 caves every
weekend they're workers on we can't say
that we had explored all Jetta cave
because it's two years or one years we
discovered new things so we are still
working inside Jetta and we will not
finish
[Music]
to play the instrument that is utilizing
our gentle earth it's like you are
becoming one with the instrument in a
very true way you just sit and go yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're looking at the grates to leg pipe
organ of the Luray Caverns in Luray
Virginia when I press a key it sends an
electrical pulse up to a rubber tipped
mallet which strikes the Select eye
causing it to vibrate and producing a
incredibly beautiful musical tone the
area that the strikers cover is roughly
three and a half acres which then makes
it literally the world's largest musical
instrument it is a very gentle sound of
very peaceful there's only one like it
in the world and it's something
incredibly different and wonderfully
beautiful
[Music]
a hundred and fifty feet underground in
30 million year old caves an
unforgettable sight glitters in the dark
the Waitomo glowworm caves in new
zealand are home to about 30,000 endemic
Iraq no Campa lumen OSA glowworms they
spend their days spinning silk nests
from the ceilings
and then lowering threads to fish for
prey much like a spider the luminescent
bead like strings are spellbinding the
glow worms use light to attract prey and
burn off waste the glow is created by a
combination of chemicals given off by
the glow worm and the oxygen in the air
the caves are ideal for the worms as
they need a dark damp location where
their light can be seen the waitomo
caves they call home are named after the
Maori words way which means water and
Tomo which means hole or shaft and
although they live deep underground the
journey to see them is never one to
disappoint when you enter a cenote it's
really like going into another world
like leaving leaving the planet behind
this is feeling of really exploring
something new and I feel very lucky to
be able to see that
[Music]
my name is Julian Bob I've been free
diving and scuba diving for the last 15
years in many different locations always
trying to find the best diving spots
those sonatas are our caves
although scientists are connected to
each others and the water goes and flows
from one state to another cenote to end
up in the sea the first time you go into
cenote it's something you don't see
anywhere else
it's completely different experience
than diving in the ocean at the
beginning it can be a little bit scary
but really quickly the beauty of the
place will just take over some
scientists are very welcoming sometimes
so big and so clear that it really gives
you the sensation you go into a church
and you don't want to talk too loud to
not disturb anyone and some of the
cenotes I also have a little bit like an
atmosphere more like hell with dead
trees and bottom and and sulfur the
Mayans were using the cenotes for a very
long time basically the land where we
are that's the place where you live in
people lives and then hundred
the cenotes into the brown was the place
for the dead every sinner to have a
different personality but I also think
that he really affects your own
personality at some point you kind of
enter into like a meditation stage if
it's for me is completely priceless
[Music]
underneath the Turkish region of
Cappadocia a system of hidden tunnels
and caves when undiscovered for a
thousand years until one man decided to
renovate his home 18 stories below the
ground level in the Turkish region of
Cappadocia is the ancient hidden city
that include the city was rediscovered
in 1963 when a man knocked down a wall
in his basement and stumbled across a
hidden room this triggered an excavation
of the area to reveal the hidden city
that is a thousand years old and over
280 feet deep it is thought to have been
created during the Byzantine era around
1000 AD to protect the community from
wars and natural disasters it is made up
of a network of tunnels connecting what
would have been kitchens stables
churches wells and even schools the
Cappadocia region is known for
subterranean safe havens and it's
speculated that Dan and qu you may have
connected many of them the city likely
could have hidden 20,000 people
livestock and food supplies making it
the largest underground city in
Cappadocia
like a scene out of frozen in the
mountains of Shanxi Province in northern
China by the Lewisohn mountains Ning Wu
ice caves a spectacle of icicles ice
Falls and AI stalagmites these caves are
thought to have formed around three
million years ago during an early Ice
Age and while there are many caves like
this around the world
the Nimue caves are special for one
particular reason this cave stays frozen
all year long while temperatures can
reach up to 70 degrees outside in the
summer the temperature inside never
rises above 32 degrees scientists
believe this is due to the caves natural
bowling pin shape which traps cold air
inside stretching thousands of feet down
the top 300 feet are open to the public
with five layers connected by a winding
maze of ice stairs holes and bridges
established as a national park in 2005
the caves are staged with colorful
lights emphasizing the grandness of this
ancient cavern it is truly a sight to
behold
you